sensation sensations le mag
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
sensation en partenariat avec tv 78
aujourd'hui je reçois amandine thibault
programmatrice salle usine à chapeaux à
rambouillet et clément prot directeur de
l'usiné à chapeaux bonjour alors votre
salle de concert a été touché comme
beaucoup de salles et de théâtre par la
crise sanitaire vous avez dû fermer
pendant plusieurs mois au mois de juin
dernier est ce que vous avez pu
reprogrammer certains cancers alors oui
on a pu reprogrammer un certain nombre
de concerts et puis surtout on a bâti en
a un temps un peu record toute une
programmation spécifique pour l'été
culturel
pendant lequel on a proposé un concert
gratuit en extérieur chaque semaine de
tout l'été et puis un certain nombre
d'autres interventions artistiques dans
différents quartiers de la ville de
rambouillet voilà pour essayer on va
dire presque de de compenser même si ce
sera jamais tout à fait possible toute
la l'arrêt de nos activités culturelles
l'année d'avant et c'était important
pour vous justement de de proposer des
concerts chaque semaine pendant cet été
alors oui parce que ben bien sûr c'est
d'abord le lien avec le public qui nous
a beaucoup manqué avec bien sûr les
rangs bullet 1 et puis tous les
spectateurs habituels le lisier d'un
chapeau et puis de pouvoir leur faim
voilà de 2,2 de pouvoir aussi accueillir
les artistes qu'on avait prévu
d'accueillir qu'on a reporté pour
certains trois ou quatre fois de suite
voilà de pouvoir enfin les accueillir
chez nous dans les conditions les plus
adaptées à la situation du moment et
puis et puis de proposer voilà dès l'été
des concerts gratuits pour le public
pour vraiment retrouver ce lien direct
qui nous est cher et au delà de l'été
culturel est ce que cette fermeture vous
a permis de réfléchir à différents
projets alors oui il ya eu il ya eu
différents enfin voilà une fois qu'on a
encaissé le choc de l'arrêt brutal des
activités bon bah déjà il a fallu
réinventer des nouvelles choses et donc
on a aussi proposé des concerts des
captations de spectacles au risque des
captations de concerts originale
diffusée sur youtube et sur notre site
internet donc donc ça nous a permis
voilà de d'inaugurer un peu ce nouveau
format avec des artistes qui ont accepté
de jouer le jeu dans des environnements
à hyper fort et du patrimoine de la
ville notamment de rambouillet ou à
d'autres endroits et alors on va parler
ensemble de la programmation des mois de
septembre et octobre vous débutez votre
saison avec le trottoir d'en face en
première partie le public pourra
découvrir ou redécouvrir camille esteban
une partie rock et une partie rap pour
cette soirée parlez nous un petit peu de
l'univers musical de ces artistes qui
est passé par rock et rap c'est pas
grave alors justement dit moi l'univers
de césar mais sait on est plus sûre de
la chanson chanson française
effectivement tenté un peu de rock voilà
un festif public le public touché par
cette musique est plutôt familiale
ouvert à tous voilà pour tout âge très
dansant dynamique ce qu'il faut pour
commencer ouvrir et ouvrira les buts et
la saison c'est très bien de le
reprendre parce que vous êtes les
professionnels de la chanson le 30
septembre barbara prat vie sera à la
lanterne on va écouter un extrait de sa
chanson revient pour l'hiver et on en
parle juste après
c'est pas sympa
il pleut des feuilles multicolores
il ce m
je suis seul et j'ai le coeur
j'entends les autres et au dehors
monsieur l'a fait
chambas
de toi toi les vêtements libre a beau
l'emporter trois pubs et frissonner
dedans et regarder tourner temps s'il te
plaît alors qu'elle est l'univers
musical de barbara préavis et l'embarras
vis et de la chanson française
engagée très douche qui donne je trouve
de l'espoir qui fait réfléchir je n'ai
pas un quidam heures
qui donne envie aussi d'aider les
gouttes et les gens je trouve ya un bon
message derrière et puis oui beaucoup de
douceur tout ça et puis d'engagement
alors la chanteuse a représenté la
france à l'eurovision avec voilà c'est
important pour l'usiné à chapeaux
d'inviter des grands chanteurs et
concerts parce que kia barbara préavis
mais on le verra au fil de la
programmation il ya d'autres grands noms
finalement de la chanson c'est important
pour vous oui et puis ça en portant ou
ici ce que barbara travail était
programmé plus tôt en mars 2020 donc
avant que tout ça se passe
donc oui c'est important aujourd'hui
c'est un grand monde avait aussi décidé
de la soutenir avant que l'eurovision
arrive que ce buzz arrive aussi pour
elle et c'est amplement mérité donc oui
oui ça faisait nous fait très plaisir
mais on est ravi d'accueillir de grandes
et vous justement en tant qu' en tant
que directeur de théâtre
permettre justement aux yvelinois de
d'avoir des concerts avec des gens
connus c'est important oui alors c'est
pas c'est pas forcément une fin en soi
mais mais en tant que tel en effet nous
nos missions notre rôle c'est d'être des
défricheurs et de et de découvrir un peu
de sentir un peu tous les courants
faibles des tendances artistiques et des
différents projets qui nous sont
proposés ou qui arrivent jusqu'à nos
oreilles et puis bah d'être un maillon
de la chaîne de développement d'un
artiste alors parfois comme c'est le cas
sur barbara préavis amandine l'a dit ben
on était là avant et puis finalement les
aléas du coc vides ont fait que le
concert n'aura lieu que là sur cette
saison et qui s'est passé tout ça pour
elle entre temps donc on est aussi très
content al'inverse qu'elle soit et que
son équipe soit resté fidèle à ses
engagements avec nous puisqu'il ya aussi
des artistes qui disent bon maintenant
j'ai plus besoin des petites salles pour
pour pour me faire connaître oui voilà
ça ne fasse pas votre seul credo
d'invités justement des gens connus vous
voulez aussi avoir des artistes
émergents finalement ça ne s'est
vraiment nos missions même si voilà nous
on sait que la notion de découverte
d'artistes c'est très différent d'une
personne à l'autre d'une génération à
l'autre en fonction du degré de à quel
point on s'intéresse aux nouveautés
musicales ou autres pour plein de gens
et on est très contents barbara prat vie
ce sera une artiste d ouverte et encore
une artiste découverte on est très
content d'y contribuer alors que pour
d'autres elle serait déjà devenu
mainstream fin voilà c'est une histoire
de point de vue et alors le 2 octobre
les fans de l itgi comme moi pourrons
rencontrer les trois artistes pour un
moment des changes pour recontextualiser
à li ji sortent chaque année des summer
où elles reprennent les différentes
musiques du top 50 quel est le programme
de cette rencontre alors la rencontre
avec donc les filles elijah le groupe et
c'est une master class donc il y aura ça
va être divisé en deux temps un premier
temps où les participants vont échanger
avec les filles autour de la thématique
la place de la femme dans les musiques
actuelles donc échanger sur leur
ressenti leur vécu leurs expériences et
puis dans un second temps alors c'est
ouvert aux musiciens mais mais pas que
par ailleurs tous les fans autres
peuvent venir mais elles vont reprendre
et travailler avec les participants du
coup un summer en fait et du coup le
travaillant ensemble et ensuite le
proposait la faim en conclusion et ça
c'est vrai ce sera le 2 octobre de 15h à
17h30 le 15 octobre on continue avec un
groupe connu en france ils ont
d'ailleurs fait parler d'eux en chantant
une souris verte dans le jardin de
l'elysée et devant le président de la
république on va écouter un extrait de
came tard et on en parle juste après
[Musique]
lens
alors ultra vomit tu le 15 octobre à
l'usiné à chapeaux on l'a entendu c'est
du métal mais est-ce qu'on peut le
qualifier comme du métal comique alors à
long terme par dusko à la lanterne
alors oui on peut le définir comme du
métal comique oui certes mais pas que ça
reste avant tout ici du métal donc c'est
esthétique que de folie mittal aime tant
alors justement pour pour essayer de
comprendre entre la lanterne et l'usiné
à chapeaux est ce qu'il ya une
différence ou est-ce que vous vous
chargez de la programmation des deux
salles alors la lanterne c'est le sait
le centre culturel vraiment
piloter en direct par la ville de
rambouillet qui n'accueille pas que de
la musique qui accueille aussi du
théâtre de la danse des expos tout ça et
nous en tant que partenaires culturels
du territoire historique on a un
partenariat qui fait qu on programme un
certain nombre de concerts de musiques
actuelles de notre de notre coeur de
métier à la lanterne donc qui nous
permet nous va d'accueillir des artistes
qui nécessite une une jauge plus grande
puisque on peut aller jusqu'à 900 places
à la lanterne là où chez nous c'est une
petite salle de moins de 300 places et
du coup voilà ça nous ça nous permet de
proposer des conditions d'accueil
différentes et donc des typologies
d'artistes différents mais on est on est
en partenariat alors pour pour la
dernière date d'octobre ce sera achille
qui sera à l'usiné à chapeaux c'est une
autre qui serait à l'usiné à chapeaux
donc c'est un artiste émergent qui a
déjà une certaine notoriété dans le
milieu de l'as de la musique en deux
mots c'est quoi achille achille c'est un
mélange de chansons
d'électro avec quelques sonorités
urbaines ce que certains peuvent définir
un peu de la pop urbaine aujourd'hui
voilà c'est un très bon musicien qui
joue du violon et du piano depuis des
années qui est donc en auteur
compositeur
assez assez bien repérer identifier sur
qui fait environ 1 ou 2 millions de vues
sur youtube on peut retrouver plus
d'informations et la billetterie sur le
site usine à chapeaux point fr merci
beaucoup clément pro et amandine
thibault d'avoir été avec nous et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez vous sur notre site et
applications radio sensations
m